[Music] That's
right, Chairman Cook, that's what many people say
] In
1937, I used several today for the first time, so I have to spend 80 years this year.
This is the first time I live. My grandmother opened the door
.  I can say that it is one of the
few New Year's vacancies,
so Korean people like alcohol very
much.  He drank a lot of water, and
now he keeps telling us that the river water dried in the rice is rich in sugar,
and the beef brisket in the beggar is rich in it
It is said that it is more helpful
now that our 5 refurbished old grandfathers are again providing
mukbang as it is.
Aww, I’m just now cooking almost the same as before.
[Music]
Yes, I’m still eating president pops every day
. I think it’s the most delicious food in the world.
And I can say that it tastes like that without burden. Whenever it's
hot, I eat it thinking about the old people.
Now I can think that it would be good to continue to pass it on until the next time.
When there is a league, do
n't fold the arrangement so that you can meet people with good taste
Oh, my name is Kim Baek-
sang in the whole country. The reason for resistance from the Joseon Dynasty in Korea is a person who brews traditional
wine.
Oh, right now, when
he passed away, he was running a sheep allowance, so my family has passed on like this for 5 generations and did it to me.
Oh, looking at it, there are
many different ingredients for its life, but
it can be seen that alcohol made from rice is the most primitive alcohol because it is made from rice and comes from our land.
Then, on the first
day of March again, the first day of March
is a traditional Korean makgeolli for about 100 days. First of all, it is said
to be sour and fluffy.
I can't read a little these days, so I'm not sure if it's just ordinary young people, or 100 people with the old people,
so there's a Shin Eun-seong,
and I'm not dancing like this in Seoul, the cultural center of Korea, the cultural center of Korea.
I wish I could find more variety
. There is no country without culture.
Alcohol is a very strong part
of culture. Then, Sue tells us that culture is something that we must have and that we must keep and develop this
[music]
Ah  Ah ah ah
[Applause]
When you first learn prenatal education, it’s like
dancing
now  It is active as a human cultural property, and
I am currently serving as the head of the Taekkyeon One Research Institute at Shilli Joo. I am
in charge of the education of my son, who was trained in the delivery paddy field, and in charge
of the overall affairs of Taekkyeon.
From now on, it
is a battle wife with a school kite history that has been handed down from the era to goggles 2,000 years ago
[Music] Because the
process of fertilization
is divided into these three stages.  With that basic
skill, you will mark something that you can actually do while watching and performing the night stage while you are practically in good spirits, tying and swapping each other with the other person.
If you use kick technique and file distance technique
, it will become
a child's
net for practical practice.  Isn't it now that radish essence to nurture
?
Of course, not only the jet breaking, but also the door
of tamu.
Music]
All Print Ring Guide Seoul Digital Editor's Broadcast
Today, I will introduce you to various foods at Gwangjang Castle.
The history goes back to the late Joseon Dynasty. Start of Rice Square
at Gin Station. As long as Korea's long history, various foods are loaded  This is
Gwangjang Market
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] Because
it’s our old days, it’s a traditional food, so we started eating from the old days and we’re together now.
That kind of
memory
[Music]
wee I made a lot of dumplings since I was little.
I used to make a lot of dumplings with it in the
past, I made it rolls at the Kujeong-hyeon temple, and before the explanation, I had to do it all over the
house. But these days, in the era of loafer, I don't make a lot of manju at home
[Music] If I do
n't spread this moment, I'm rich
Chang 4th July
I eat a lot of town, but I'm dizzy, but I'm not. I steam my son with my drink, Arthur
Healer. No, the kids are still walking terribly
.  I ordered
it, and I am trying to make it. After that, I proudly developed it and
there was only
one at my house. I gave 6 each, and I also gave the 2nd
octopus. It is easy to rain, and the texture is very unique.
It's
becoming more common.
Did you see
[Music]
Ah for uh
2 Now, not only all books in the digital age, but all technology is going to the
cake, but
the biggest advantage of being able to call is the weird taste of typography
[Music
] Rolf in Lima I don't know
2  sc link e jjori ks chung-up soup lee amen
sports maps of kan chui soup ending Hells
Thatcher is Park Han-seo, who runs the trial city printing studio
.  It is the only printing house in Korea that makes books.
So, the mandarin 8 spelling is Suwon you've, and the ace is sold and the borrowing
center is also paper. As we have dermatitis, Mr. Bo is excellent.
Hera is rightly short.
After that, I cut my feet  You
can make the 8 characters in here with 2 milk. After you put them in, you have to
pick out the Chinese characters. Now, you can squeeze out the printed pages one by one. Then
, if you go through the steps,
you can't get my page
with it.  It will come out as soon as the print is finished
[music]
uh nq aix Warhead rib bang punching magnetic error code
reader S-class facial surface
withdrawal after deuce printing Combining Jikji, shimcheyojeol, good in 1377
Invented nearly 70 years before Temeraire  It can be said that this is the biggest advantage of the Korean sensor.
Me and the roll work at the stadium, I come to the shiap sebre, and the fire can be performed
.  It can be printed quickly and economically, but the book is not in the 5th level. I understand
the work
and rf sma male excel morse paging sray Sora has been able to fit into the soul fish
job.
I can't explain the feeling of this book that I shot with words
. You can tell the difference only when you see it yourself
[Music]
4 2